you feel like if you're about to climax
and then you look at this would it would
it help you over to make you stop you
know I feel bad man know what it's like
to be the girl to like sign off on that
waiver to know that you're getting
desperate times man desperate to know if
they're doing that then man she's like
hey I got my image out there you know
she's like $10 $20 $20 I like could be
worse could be good be good be dead yeah
that's like a prank gift or like a gag
gift right not necessarily I bet people
are tired of coming on their iPads in
lazy gamer News submitted by its rainin
Pringles wants to use its gaming headset
that feeds you chips love that it's a
pretty self-explanatory article that is
so cool why does she look panicked and
somebody in a circle sees her she's like
but I'm hungry at the same time dude
that sounds like a dream I would love to
play games and just well someone fed you
no joke I guess so so there was a night
where we had like a whole bunch of stuff
that we needed to do for stat boost
right and I was like oh yeah but I'm
kind of tired right so I kind of took a
nap and I fell asleep I basically just
fell asleep arbitrary so the Nelsons
like well I guess I'm just up doing this
all this work by myself right so he
reaches over I guess I'm just gonna do
all this work by myself story right so I
guess that's what he was thinking and he
goes over to like our snack bag because
bought some snacks and he took out like
a butt like a potato does he open it and
immediately he saw my hand right in
front of his face like heard the bag
open I mean muting my head was like my
friend the cow agape I guess he Hugh
sleep he was staying at in the middle of
the day and then his sister like me -
brows or something
oh I was like specific yeah it was a hot
meal right it was like hey Danny what's
up and it uses like sure I guess
hey but he was still asleep so she plays
tell honey cheek what is that like mark
on your face the misters all those
third-degree burns on his face I'm like
can't wait God you woke up in the pain I
think geez not like immediately it was
enough way of burned
what the hell cuz like you coward me
like I would be like I would feel the
birther oh [ __ ] what the hell like you
know what as what does but when you get
back hash browns
oh yeah you got you have eventually yeah
I mean I'm glad wait what was the
alternative you just didn't get up so
tired to actually see through that yeah
yeah so this is 3d printed so it's a I
think it's a prototype I don't think
that they've entered full production is
making the headset themselves yeah just
released a chip dispensing gaming head
so that automatically feeds you a
patented patented chips please wait bulb
awaits wait for the name the headset is
appropriately called the hunger hammer
hunger sound so scary see that it's like
so Goomer it is very gamers like hey
fuel is the RGB notice RGB then that's
really truly gamer do you think it looks
like a what does she think it looks
she's surprised is that no she's ready
for a [ __ ] The Hunger hammering it
looks kinda like this but what this
reminds me of is like you know you know
beer koozie are not beer koozies do the
beer hats have to be the straws yeah
yeah the [ __ ] River engine but
instead of like beers there you have
like chips
yeah but then also it has haven't got
Mike yeah beginning Ed's alright what if
that is the Mike so whatever feed you
your voice gets a little bit louder
crunching noises just oh yeah that's
right because it is right there how does
it operate it's funny because like the
picture looks like it there is no Mike I
don't know if the mike is attached to
the actual like swinging a harbour or
maybe this is attached to my headset I
mean like Gare politan [ __ ] it's like
hit it yeah it's like right here maybe
it was a video to show me yeah well
apparently there's gamers like crikey
index bonus and strip in Vegas there's
streamers on I don't know who the hell
the streamers yeah the spirit of games
looks like any other gamers there are
popular online gamers but there they've
been testing them on Twitch hilarious
effect it hasn't been going in their
mouth properly or is it I don't know I
think been hammering them with chips
what if it was like like a pneumatic
like a overly aggressive pneumatic
engines in your mouth and then it's just
the Joker know how I got these scars
[ __ ] hungry chip you tooth I chipped
my tooth before you see well one of them
was really hungry one of them and uh
well you in a rocker no no
I wasn't excited to eat and I bit
directly into the fork and it's like an
indent with a fork but I've done that
before I just did it again this past
weekend oh you ever thought of like
slowing down is my it's my tooth okay do
I have another chip and she was like
besides what you already have no thanks
yeah my chipped tooth stories are not so
great
No yeah which tooth he is this one
remember what did you get what's it
called not a veneer that were the other
one no I don't get it filled I think
like what my dentist said was like the
kind of sand it down think about doing
that yeah I mean I don't like the way it
looks okay yeah because I have yes all
right cuz I did that because I don't
only reason why I chipped my tooth is
because I tripped Oh crazy snacking
story while you're asleep and you're
just like and then I add some rocks I I
chipped my molar but it was crazy cuz I
didn't even know it's like the biggest
dude yeah but it's like one of the was I
don't know if I was the mole in the very
back but it was one of the back teeth
right here so I'm assuming was one of
the molars but they were like my dentist
was like you know you chipped your tooth
I'm like yeah there's like a little tube
chip there I'm like oh you have no idea
how I'm pretty sure I really like I
don't know if we're really hungry
English toffee have you guys ever had
toffee yeah yeah it's hard it's like
yeah so I've that's the only thing that
I've [ __ ] up my braces with cuz you
named Esposito there's Tommy but my mom
makes really [ __ ] good English talk
it's homey homemade English okay yeah
well I'll make I'll make a batch it's
really easy to make I'll make a batch I
share with oh you guys you should makes
it during the holidays to you I'll tell
her to make a batch it's got it's got
almonds inside and then it's covered in
chocolate and then you put walnuts on
top
[ __ ] good but anyway so I want to
break my tea I've been my favorite like
Christmastime like snacks is melted
butter and sugar so I think that's what
I ended up cracking it on but I didn't
notice it until the other dentist told
me but he was like well it's you're not
in pain and it's not really affecting
anything else so I guess we'll just
leave it I'm like well yeah I mean
pretty I think I've been pretty fresh
bill cracked yeah so crack but it's like
hey now gonna see it because it kind of
fits with like how the rest of like that
chunkiness little more over time let me
set the brace - did you know I just
what do you mean you get more than one
cell I mean I guess you can you can go
back and do it again engage like you I
had two sets my upper row of teeth were
so bad that back in fourth grade I had
to get one
no oh it's just regular braces so it's
just the top and then middle school I
had a full set until high school and got
those staying off these are my teeth now
yeah he stole her retainer I have a top
retainer when I have a permanent
retainer cemented in what is that like
what is a permanent people say like it's
here you might be able to see like like
see it yeah I wonder get that close to
your mouth yeah you barely see it's
really annoying affects you you keep
wanting to touch it with your tongue
yeah yeah until you've had this for over
over 10 years the only difference is
whoa these two teeth have cement on it
so it's not like the opposite way it's
like where it's like this it's or
concave it's more a little bit more
convex so they have the cement mixer guy
come in and they just pour it in my
mouth yeah good thing yeah I used to
have it and then like it it broke
because I think my wisdom teeth are
finally growing in oh like my teeth is
like kind of shifting out of place look
at the wire and it's nothing and
sometimes I would cut my mom's always
been to convention to get braces and I
was like mom like wipers I was like okay
we'll talk about it that just never like
we have to remove some teeth and I was
like but no you're not removing tea
[ __ ] use wooden braces fine but you're
not taking teeth out like permanently
like they're like yeah this was at a
point where they like to work at a girl
I hear a lot of times when you get
braces they have to remove some so that
sometimes to move [ __ ] and I was just
like [ __ ] that so my mom proceeded for
the next [ __ ] 20 years of my life
every time I see her even now sometimes
she's like look at your teeth you could
be so much more handsome
[Laughter]
you'd be attractive if you had better
teeth I did a pretty good job you know
the one thing one thing I couldn't just
pull together right there that's the
vimi's way my mom has this weird
superstition that like she's like I'm
not gonna let you take all your wisdom
teeth out at once because you'll die oh
she's like oh I my friends friends kid
got all their wisdom teeth taken out at
once and they died so that applies to
everybody yeah every other kid who gets
they all take it out there like they
were the lucky ones yeah I'm like it's
my money I will spend it on getting it
all done at once
it's my money and I buy wisdom teeth are
hella impacted too they're like here's
my molar
I'll let took out two and then here's my
wisdom tooth Oh anyone hurt noodle
surgery yeah but it doesn't hurt yet oh
my Vitamix has dentist like so I I hear
some people like experience is pretty
smooth well mine like to take it out
pitch meet up was like standing on top
of me like just [ __ ] [ __ ] into my
jaw I could feel its entire weight Oh
goodbye
you've entire weight on my job I was
just like
I think you I think you'll be okay like
hey if you think another one could I
could you put me to sleep or something
cuz I heard people do that yeah he's
like I've never heard of people it
starts as gas and just start his [ __ ]
dremel tool my [ __ ] dad went to
Mexico to get it done he I would know it
was here I walk across the border and
then he got a gun came back okay I hear
about people doing that and like plastic
surgery and Shelley cut in Mexico
I'm like bro there's nothing that I want
that badly that I need that because I've
actually covered on JK news it's never
something that's like life threaten some
kind of cosmetic that's like cosmetic
[ __ ] I I had a I had somebody I knew in
high school like the rumor was like when
she turned 16 or whatever like her
parents took her to Mexico to get booted
to get a boob job so like I heard that
they're definitely they were definitely
pretty pretty perky like I didn't I mean
like they look you need your I
definitely enjoyed them yeah they're you
need your ride was like yes those are
boobs hey Plus uh my boobs my boobs look
great now but I don't have nipples
anymore like down here I turn around and
I had some on my boy
[Music]